[Music]
so I don't know why I didn't Disney's
live-action remake of Beauty and the
Beast is a hit here are several big
changes to the plot and characters from
the original the 1991 animated version
starts with the narration over a push
into the beasts castle and a series of
stained glass windows this narration
explains how the prince was unkind to
the Enchantress dressed as a beggar in
the live-action film the story starts at
a party at the princes castle where he
shuns and Moxie enchantress in disguise
in front of guests in both films the
prince is transformed into a beast and
his staff has turned into various
household objects their fate is bound
with the princes ability to find someone
to love him before the last petal of the
enchanted rose falls on his 21st
birthday if he can't do this in the
original film he stays a beast forever
and his staff remains household objects
in the new version the curse takes
things a step further the Prince can't
break the spell and we become enemies in
addition the curse spreads to the whole
village that makes them forget all about
the castle including their wives and
husbands and sides it also creates a
perpetual winter around the castle Belle
finds the beasts castle and both films
and offers to take her father's place in
the new live-action version she actually
makes an escape after Belle starts to
nurse the Beast back to health in both
films the relationship begins to change
this Illustrated into something they are
song scenes where Bell starts a snowball
fight in the original she evades the
Beast froze when he drops his giant
snowball on his head but in the new
version she gets hit in the face with a
snowball the character of Gaston is
notorious for his sexism and arrogance
in the original animated film the
live-action film humanizes his character
by toning down his brashness and adding
a backstory as a war hero his sidekick
Lefou also gets the care
to upgrade while he's fumbling and silly
in the original he is much whittier and
well-rounded in the new film the iconic
Gaston song and the tavern also gets an
update it includes new lyrics that
didn't make it into the original an
incredible choreography let us know what
you think about the rest of the changes
in the film and the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]